estaban para ayudar pero aprovecharon la
confianza para abusar una comisión
independiente encargada por la
organización mundial de la salud detectó
83 presuntos perpetradores de abuso
sexual entre 2018 y 2020 los hechos
ocurrieron durante la respuesta de la
agencia de la salud de la onu a un brote
de ébola en la república democrática del
congo 21 de los implicados eran
trabajadores de la o ms 4 todavía
trabajaban para el organismo am soria lo
siento en soria y formato están lamento
lo que hicieron las personas empleadas
en la o ms para servir y proteger
lamentó el sufrimiento continuo que esos
hechos han causado en short y ford y on
going shaffer in that this events must
goes
empleos a cambio de relaciones sexuales
nueve posibles violaciones y extorsiones
a mujeres abusadas para que aportaran
tras el informe en lado ms prometió
actuar de inmediato con apoyo protección
y justicia para víctimas y
sobrevivientes
abordando las fallas de gestión y
personal de la organización y con una
reforma estructural y cultural
en lado ms estamos realmente conmovidos
horrorizados y desconsolados por los
resultados de la investigación enjuague
los últimos años se han sucedido las
investigaciones que desvelan que altos
mandos de la oms fueron informados de
estas denuncias además de no haber
conseguido detener el acoso habrían
ascendido a uno de los responsables es
el mayor caso de delitos sexuales para
una agencia de la onu desde los cascos
azules acusados de abusar más de dos mil
mujeres en haití entre 2004 y 2017